um so yes we got another video from
Jubilee you know what's funny is Jubilee
was in one of my favorite cartoons x-men
and she was the most detestable
character yeah cuz every time she showed
up she would just shoot fireworks and
everyone be like get this off the screen
why would she just shoot fire he was so
useless useless the weirdos
boys actually ripping the boys boy
[Music]
hi I'm amber I'm 22 years old
I collect pressed pennies 51 cents is
the way to my heart yo ya Jubilee
scouting team finds the corniest people
they Wow I'm makenzie I'm 21 years old
and a million people I've seen me make
out with a boy online millions of people
to see me make out with a boy I'll
imagine if a guy was just sitting there
like that's wifey material right there
if a guy would say that I would have
said that to present himself they were
said as a boy 20 I'm a full-time
destination wedding photographer and I'm
a yoga instructor on the side too
I'm actually from Amish country
Pennsylvania hey literally have
Mennonite and Amish children at my house
for a first date I would just love it if
we could go to Whole Foods and just like
look for organic quinoa for us to eat
together yeah and I love yoga so if
you'd like to engage in some Sun posts
[Music]
hi my name is Vitoria I'm 26 years old
I'm a social-media influencer Yoshi
proudly said I'm a social-media
influencer boo-boo you are the
definition of a yeah the gave me cancer
these people are mad corny oh this is
just a corn fest you know what it's your
fault it's all your fault
you can't go for Jubilee videos you know
what to expect you go there and you hit
on them it's like you know what to
expect
yes yes I do let's carry on
whoa you like oh you know what this made
me feel like like in my track days when
we're doing track and field and we're
about to run 100 100 meters people do
the most and they don't need to do this
guy looks like a sperm about to swim up
a uterus what's up with this excitement
I don't know what it is but hey I'm fine
everything fine how's your day been
are we going right now I don't know if
we're gonna be able to finish this I'm
not gonna lie to you can you not that's
my couch bro bro
now I'm in time you saw me with a
[ __ ] dog did you drop something you
have a really good figure Alison you go
just to carry my emotional baggage man
as brutal bro that's brutal you know I
like about these things is like you
already know that they're not picking
nobody off person out there gonna think
always a good look and do that everyone
so in this group is gonna be the tall
dude I'm not in a small talk know about
me I got injured and I'm resulted from
that start getting into yoga lot more
get into nature get into the little bit
of Kundalini Yoga okay it's kinda back
look at the guy in the back he's not wit
you no no okay that's no you just
organically along we're gonna finish
this carry on its go okay
I play the cowbell oh yeah I play cello
for an orchestra
I don't know what's happening bro I
don't know how they fit this much cringe
I don't know how they did it bro I play
the cello how about you play this
normally we try to be very insightful
and I give you guys breakdowns on what
you shouldn't do if you don't know oh
actually no you're right double for
those two whether you call it God or the
universe air source it's still just love
and my connection social connection you
know what this is the part where they
all struggle and they have to look like
it's hard for them just so that they
don't appear like a bad person they know
I'm probably going to eliminate so are
you sort of a free-spirited soul nomadic
what are you like settling down and
being having that balances what's your
favorite type of body of water the
oceans you know the waves they come in
come out moon gets affected by a lot of
things just making up a lot of stuff so
these guys on to talk with national you
you I'm Vietnamese okay how are you guys
I'm Chinese and Filipino so chill oh my
god oh my god take a deep breath both 9
o matic journey I actually used to live
out of my soup okay why should I pick
you why should you pick me yeah I'm very
susceptible to peer pressure so whatever
you say is it's probably gonna work if
one day
you need to sleep with the Chinese next
to you I will be there I just like
flowing and listening to my intuition
and let go then just go I like the guy
beside it was like imma let this guy
talk himself out of the competition he
hasn't spoken at all he's been standing
there like a tree because he talked so
much because he knows he's gonna win we
should pick me because I can cook
whatever you'd like for me to cook as
good as to play guitar and cello you
said you loved the cello it's so fine oh
okay okay okay okay take a deep breath
take a deep breath
I feel like I've talked to you so much
now you know no worries I'm gonna go and
just have a nomadic journey over there
yeah listen if you guys are still here
with us at this point in this video she
want to say you guys are loyal and we
appreciate you for cringing with us
through this
that was nerve-racking standing there
and like who's gonna pick you why are
they picking you it's probably just
based off of initial traction like you
don't really know anything about each
other right away I mean just being next
to a pretty girl is like hot I like
making me smile enough they're all so
good they all have so many great quality
appreciate and I feel like what if I
mean no offense what if I made the wrong
choice
yeah definitely never done
I'd be very dumb for that I'd be open to
it's going phenomenal it's always an
excellent day my friend it was more so
just like myself wanting to bring out my
experiences of similarities that I see
in her I was just wanted her to know
about it it was just like yeah it's cool
though okay all right any thoughts you
[Laughter]
there's literally nothing insightful
about this at all
hey preach wouldn't pick a journey a
little mad at journey with me let's go
to goober town I know what you did why
why you did that
so I guess recommend it to ya use my
phone see I got King Jubilee videos be
commenting on my phone that's why I got
two phones cuz it pieces like you brah
you did that alright listen that's ya
[Music]
[Applause]